when I speak about a four-dimensional  creature that can take the yolk from an  egg without breaking the shell I'm not  treating thyme as the fourth dimension  I'm talking about four dimensions of  space and then add one of time on top of  that a one-dimensional creature living  on a line could experience time so could  my friend in the second dimension  we have three dimensions of space in our  world and one of time but what's there  to stop us from imagining a world with  four five or a hundred spatial  Dimensions that also experiences the  progression of time well our brains  might be incapable of truly imagining it  but we can try and we have math to help  us describe it